you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess cube
gonna play a 960 game 2389 player and
let's see how we could
go about things here Thanks
I thought I just typed high didn't work
I keep court isn't working okay
oh man this is not a good start to a
chess game I can't even type I don't
know what's going on okay I got double H
I got a chart anything but hi
how to begin this is my first thought
just playing c5 mm my queen to come out
what's unprotected I like this is a
start this guy is probably gonna want to
play to this square so actually maybe I
want to do this instead hmm how do we
castle trying to investing some time
here because I'm trying to come up with
a plan with this configuration
let's try well all right well after all
that let's try let's okay let's go at c5
what we call this Sicilian defense
probably not right all right let's see
let's try this maybe they're thinking
about getting this move in I don't want
to allow that so easily and there I
guess they're gonna get it in if they
really want to get it in they're gonna
get it in let's go with this my maybe
that's why I wasn't able to type my
computers kind of freezing up on me a
little bit so it's gonna have to roll
with it and I need more development I
was gonna do this move but that's no
good because of night there and I think
I lose upon so let's not um
this King might be vulnerable to this
diagonal maybe oh how do I do it my
light square bishop I gotta get him out
so I think this is maybe a good approach
now this is maybe a bit reminiscent of
like a dragon pond structure but I don't
have this guy over here on this g7
square you know my computer's definitely
freezing up if I'm needing to UM go fast
it's not gonna turn out pretty so no I
guess they're getting ready for that
move
which night do I get go I guess this one
here yeah something's going really
screwy here why was that played I don't
understand that just chop that I have
two pieces on it as well all right Queen
all right let's chop again and he's
bearing down and this diagonal I could
play Bishop here I'm gonna go with that
for the Queen's end up but she has to
recapture on this square and I need a
space for my knight I have to move this
rook before I could Castle kingside I
don't think that I should be castling
queenside here so let's get this night
out
yeah these these pieces are just like
clicking from square to square they're
not there's no animation so let's get my
queen here in my rook on this only open
file that was an interesting way to UM
get castled I wonder if they knew they
could have just played there look up and
then Castle kingside I think that that
would have been quite alright so now
Castle Knight here could be maybe a
slight inconvenience this is a passed
pawn you know what come to think of it
maybe I should have been playing my rook
to a well and pawn push here we run with
that and if Knight here I could actually
throw in an in-between move I'm gonna go
with that I'm on the Queen and now and
now I'll react to the night let's just
back up in the corner she looks kind of
sad here in the corner but I think I
could weasel out of it I'm looking to
get d5 in oh and you know what I just
did I didn't I didn't care too much
about life on right there so okay we
might have a sack followed by a pawn
push or something might be coming up but
I think I still have an advantage even
though I gave back that punish
allow that night right here could be a
pain I don't have an in-between move
there because when the night takes the
Queen it's on my rook
so if Knight here what do i do my queen
is actually constrained not fun not fun
I think I have to work myself into a pin
I know no I'm not Queen here night
they're not good let's try this I I
really have to pick up the pace
something's I'm not gonna be able to
move fast if it gets too like a mouse
race so if Knight okay and now I reek
app sure with the knight now my knight
in Queen Oh actually I'm on the I'm on
the rope right here okay so that's uh
and and the punch so am i netting some
material here also there is no knight b3
type of move I do have to be cautious of
maybe like Knight takes pawn
okay this rook could maybe be converging
on g7 but okay we don't have that like
if I were to do something crazy like a
pawn push there is Knight takes pawn
here in some variations maybe with the
Queen and rook converging on h7 a minute
10 to 256 let's see what gets done here
if the rook reacts how should I capture
on this square I think taking with the
pawn is best that way I'm not working
myself into a pin I want to make sure
that that pin is kind of resolved and oh
I think I have some this is a good plan
here looking for just checking on this
diagonal and then this King is going to
be not too happy so I'm looking at Queen
c7 giving check and also keeping close
eye on this pawn right here I'm assuming
the Queen is gonna stay around alright
let's let's throw this check in am I
missing anything no yeah you see they're
not after it's almost like I have to
click square to square if the pawn
pushes rip to the seventh is deadly and
this rook is officially out of the game
now
pawn push oh man okay seventh-ranked now
this Knight is tied down and when it's
tied down I could I could snip on this
square and I think this is game over now
I think I'm crashing through I found
that mistake and trying to exploit the
pinned pieces in fact this is losing
probably more oh this is this is bad
news now so it's just time and I should
have enough time here and now
everything's falling isn't it I'm
looking for me just trying to keep
things really simple but here's good
enough I'm just netting uh
more than a rook I'm gonna be getting
that King I'm assuming my opponent is
gonna be resigning or not okay let's
just grab that and then play my queen to
the seventh this rook I don't even need
my rook around
so let's come here and now mate threats
to many make threats to be dealing with
I'm going to move my knight next
threaten to get to this Square and
something Bad's gonna happen quickly
here so where is it hang on hang on hang
on I almost just mouse let's get this
rook here
and now now I could mate because that
Queen is pinned okay let's see if I
could type good game no it's still now
let me type okay something's gone screwy
my computer so I'll have to fix that
fortunately I didn't have to get into
like a quick mouse race with that one
but as always I hope you got something
out of this 960 game these are a lot of
fun to be playing and I think it allows
for a lot of chess creativity so I'll
catch you on the next video take care
bye